hi welcome to chili's okay i really
don't know what i'm doing with these
intros anymore ladies and gentlemen
talented ones and pale people we only
have one more episode until red tide
comes to an end
but don't fear we also have four
episodes of part two death valley but i
really don't know how they're gonna top
this incredible first part which i think
ranks up there with the first three
seasons that being said there's a ton to
unpack so if you haven't liked and
subscribed yet you know what to do
because here we go well that was fast
doris gives birth to a baby boy they'll
name eli eli is an interesting name
since it derives from hebrew meaning hi
or my god and it's commonly associated
with eli's curse wherein eli and his
descendants would die before reaching
old age the last we saw doris was in
episode 3 after she fell down the stairs
and was admitted to the hospital harry
promised her that he was going to take
alma back to new york and they were
going to leave p-town so that was a
[ __ ] lie and if harry's lies weren't
bad enough he takes the soiled bloody
linens from doris's pregnancy for a
mid-afternoon snack you're delicious
this is actually some cheeky editing
since if you watch my preview breakdowns
you'll see how they change the color
correction for this scene doris is
brought home where she is relentlessly
gaslit by alma harry and ursula the
title of this episode is gaslight and
refers to a specific type of
manipulation where the manipulator tries
to get someone to question their own
reality memory or perceptions when doris
asks why harry and alma aren't in new
york like harry had promised she's
quickly dismissed however what's more
worrisome here is alma being able to
sense the heartbeat of her brother
foreshadowing her eventual late night
feed in episode 4 we learned bel noir
could smell the blood of her victims
through their skin meanwhile looks like
mickey's speed racer deal has come
through and he's got a sick new ride for
quote research purposes you'll remember
ursula told him about this deal in
episode 3 and he's off to la and wants
karen to come with him together they can
be a power couple note the mural of the
sea in the background foreshadowing the
episode's chilling final act or the fact
mickey says to karen i'm not gonna like
walk into the surf or something stupid
like that are you yeah well mickey tries
to convince karen to take the black pill
and come with him to la she says it
isn't worth the price of admission you
see the difference between karen and
mickey is that karen never cared whether
art was good or not she painted for the
love of painting for how it made her
feel not for awards accolades fame or
money karen is so displeased with mickey
that she asked to be let out giving him
one of her iconic lines
that night doris wakes up to find a
grisly discovery of alma feeding off the
baby baby blood is the most coveted of
all blood due to its pure nature newborn
blood is the elixir of the gods
it's pure
untouched by a life of bulls and trucks
and harry isn't too pleased at his
daughter you don't feed off your brother
but how else will she be able to perfect
locately's caprice in d major alma
reveals her true colors here to her her
mother is holding them back i still
don't understand why you keep her around
we don't need her especially now this
has been a sentiment she's held for
pretty much the entire season her mother
is talentless and therefore should be
discarded ursula is here reading
presumably one of harry's new scripts
she has a lot to gain by keeping doris
gaslet as we learn at the end of the
episode her goal is to start the world's
premier literary and talent agency with
her clients juiced up on the black pill
i still can't help but think that
there's something more to ursula
something really big that will be
revealed next episode she does say the
only thing she's held longer than this
baby is a stiff drink and a grudge i'm
probably looking too deep into this but
you guys know i love theorizing not
gonna lie ursula is a huge [ __ ] here
telling doris she's talentless but
that's okay she can just live off of
harry for the rest of her life she even
takes away her suit before she's
finished because she has to start
letting go of that baby weight harry
returns from what we can assume is a
kill to feed alma and alma visits her
mother telling her it's time for her
pills not disclosing that one of them is
a black pill it's basically alma trying
to poison her own mother she wants to
poison me she wants to kill me this
causes a commotion which culminates
indoors taking the baby and fleeing the
home only to be hunted by the pale
people harry comes to her rescue and
says
they can't hurt you as long as you're
with me this protection has been hinted
at way back in episode 1 pale creatures
won't attack those who have taken the
pill so we basically have a situation
here where doris can't escape bell noir
tracks karen who's painting by the sea
and belle isn't that much of a fan of
her work now i am in a move
she wants karen to retrieve eli just
like she got her a baby in episode 1. if
she doesn't she'll no longer offer her
protection from the pale ones even
threatening to gouge out her eyes doris
awakens to find holden vaughn
overlooking her designs with harry we
learned in episode 3 that holden is a
famous interior designer it's been
implied that he too is on the black pill
considering in episode four he was a
real estate agent when showing the
chemist her soon-to-be home remember
that the only reason the gardeners are
in this home is that they got a special
deal in return for doris doing the
interior design but now that she's kind
of out of it harry has asked holden to
do the work anonymously mickey packs his
things as he gets ready for la and
offers karen yet again one of the black
pills he's essentially offering her a
way out a way where she'll no longer
need bell noir's protection but karen is
stalwart in her convictions she won't
take the pill instead asking for
mickey's help in stealing the baby to
save its life she knows that if she
doesn't get the baby belle will just
hire someone else to get it so she kind
of sees this as a sign for her life to
get back on track she'll steal the baby
get clean it'll be like a fresh start
and mickey seeing his friend in trouble
agrees to help her doris is like hey
elma don't feed off your brother and she
promises not to but alma is relentless
in pressuring her mother to take the
pill using different tactics of reverse
psychology emotional coercion and
gaslighting to break down doris's
defenses until she eventually relents
and takes the pill this is the beginning
of the end for doris because doris is
talentless the effects of the black pill
take hold she vomits on the bed and
later that night while mickey and karen
come to take the baby we see her emerge
get away from my baby
yep doris has begun the process of
transforming into a pale one just like
this dude did in episode 4. and karen is
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm out of here and
doesn't even take the baby she'll be
pursued by a gang of pale ones as mickey
comes to her aid now i don't know if
this is just a coincidence but the house
number behind them is 105 and this just
happens to be season 10 episode 5. like
mickey and karen's previous
conversations karen again refuses to
take the pill and even tells mickey he
isn't human if i'm not mistaken this is
the first time not human has been used
to describe people like mickey bell noir
and harry and with part two revolving
around aliens i can't help but think
this was a conscious choice of words and
mickey that son of a gun basically
leaves karen to die by the pale ones but
because she doesn't want to die she
takes the black pill as a last resort
it's very important that she says the
line i don't want to die since we'll see
in the final scene that she ends up
killing herself but we'll get to that in
a bit doris goes full gi jane and shaves
off the rest of her hair and once you
see that she looks exactly like benedict
cumberbatch you'll never be able to
unsee it doris ends up trying to kill
her own baby she's gone full crazy as a
result of this pill harry has to lock
her in the bathroom and finds out it was
alma who convinced her to take one of
those pills that's daughter of the year
material if you ask me karen tells
mickey that she can't believe she took
the pill and that she feels sick and
this is the one scene where i was kind
of like hey karen your friend just left
you to die why isn't this the big
emotional pull of the scene but i get
what the writers were trying to do here
they wanted to shift the narrative so we
get mickey and karen on the beach for
this climactic ending mickey basically
tells karen that she needs to feed and
that once she's fed she can create her
masterpiece like starry night or the
last supper they end up at the beach
where she's going to kill but instead of
killing a vagrant karen kills mickey so
i guess we can kiss that speed racer
reboot goodbye in karen's mind her only
friend in the world betrayed her and was
going to leave her she also thinks that
everyone who takes the black pill is
evil so her motivation for killing
mickey here isn't too crazy after she
feeds she finishes her masterpiece and i
wouldn't be surprised if this painting
might show up down the line
unfortunately we don't get a good look
at it karen then slits her wrists going
into the ocean to die she would rather
kill herself than live with having to
kill others for blood it seems like the
only characters who have any semblance
of moral integrity like doris karen and
even chief burleson have all died i
imagine next episode will be an absolute
bloodbath with most of our characters
getting their comeuppance otherwise what
is the show trying to say about the
lengths we're willing to go for art if
none of the bad guys pay harry locks
cumberbatch in the washroom after she's
pretty much turned full pale he gives
this big speech about how he thought he
was a family man first but that was just
a lie he told himself to cover up the
fact that he was a failing writer he has
now fully embraced art before family and
he ends up releasing doris into the wild
she wears these deer colored ugg boots a
call back to episode 1 where they found
a dead deer on the side of the road
deers are normally a symbol of innocence
just like doris and like a deer doris is
being set out into the wild the final
scene is between alma and ursula they're
on their way to see the chemist to
acquire more pills but this probably
won't go over well as in episode 3 the
chemist told austin and bell to kill
ursula i'll talk about this more in my
preview breakdown which will hopefully
come out later tonight but the synopsis
for next episode says that ursula
devises a sinister plan so this just
points to the theory that ursula has
something up her sleeve i'm predicting
some sort of big reveal next app and
finally we have doris fully turned into
a pale one feeding off a rabbit just
like alma did at the end of episode 2.
it's a real tragic end for her but fear
not if you liked lily rabe she'll be
returning in part 2 as amelia earhart
now we have one more episode left i
absolutely can't wait and i hope you'll
like and subscribe i'm always coming out
with new ahs videos thanks for watching
everyone keep a lookout for my preview
breakdown and for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt until next time
remember daddy loves you very much